We Begin this half hour with a
Monumental change in public conscience
and public spaces in New Jersey and
across America perhaps the most
well-known Underground Railroad
conductor Harriet Tubman's unflinching
courage and unwavering commitment stood
the test of time and now a new monument
in her honor stands in the same spot
where a statue of Christopher Columbus
once stood Elaine Keanu was there for
the good the grand unveiling
abolitionist Harriet Tubman marched to
her own drum and her Legacy was
celebrated this week in Newark New
Jersey
this soaring 25-foot Monument was a
two-year project inspired by this iconic
image of Tubman her life story is part
of an audio installation though her
heart raced with fear
followed the golden star narrated by
singer and actor Queen Latifah who was
born in Newark what is it that you hope
people take away from hearing about
Harriet Tubman's story I hope they take
away renewed strength inspiration
Humanity compassion you know what what
Harriet Tubman did was about Freedom was
about compassion for those who did not
have it Tubman escaped slavery and
risked her freedom to lead about 70
enslaved people by the Underground
Railroad a network of safe houses that
led North including this church in
Newark with hidden tunnels
at the site visitors will learn Tubman
was also a spy in the Union Army and an
advocate for women's rights and the
elderly the project was a city
partnership supported by the audio
Entertainment Company audible Don Katz
is the founder why did audible want to
be a part of this monument and be
involved in the way that you are because
we knew we could give voice to the
monument in ways that that kids can
stand in front of it and learn and
really create an experience of the depth
of Harriet Tubman's long long almost
century-long life Monument designer Nina
cook John placed a mosaic of Tubman's
face at eye level intentionally why was
that important for you you can look into
her eyes and touch her face and connect
to her Humanity it could be your mother
your aunt your grandmother and in so
doing be that much more inspired by her
taking her rightful place as she
continues to inspire for CBS Saturday
morning Elaine quijano Newark New Jersey